[Music]
[Applause]
I mentioned coming up the best shooter
in college basketball
Caitlin Clark Iowa basketball Junior
guard hit the game-winner against
Indiana and uh Indiana number two in the
nation you got the Big Ten Tournament
coming up and Caitlin Clark joins us on
loan from Iowa all right Caitlin take me
into the huddle final plays drawn up
less than two seconds to go what was
said
honestly we were kind of looking to get
the ball for a layup at The Rim we kind
of ran a play we thought our the four
player would switch out and they would
double team me which they didn't end up
doing they kind of put the person that
was guarding the inbounder in the middle
of the lane so that wasn't open and I
was the second option for the three
um and lucky enough I thought our post
player Monica Sonata set a really really
good screen kind of hit the girl and she
almost fell over a little bit which gave
me a second to get it off and you know
it's a play we practice we practice and
practice all the time against our blue
Squad which are our managers and
practice boys so um you know we had been
through that situation quite a few times
and you know 1.5 seconds was plenty of
time for me to get it off when was the
last time you didn't have a green light
in a game to shoot whenever you wanted
to
honestly you know I'm lucky enough to
play for a coach that you know has kind
of given me the keys to the offense
since I got here you know we had a we
had a point guard that had graduated
right before I came to campus and went
to the WNBA so you know that's one of
the reasons I came here go back to grade
school okay
when did you when's the first time you
were allowed to shoot whenever you
wanted to
oh man
um honestly probably as long as I can
remember
um you know I kind of always was a
little more gifted on the offensive end
um you know I grew up watching the game
I had an older brother that played
basketball so I always tagged around
with a lot of boys and I think you know
that kind of helped me like develop my
offensive skill set at a younger age a
little faster than most people would and
then when I made that transition from
boys basketball to girls basketball I
was you know already kind of a step
ahead
um and you know I always had the will to
want to be better
um you know and I played up usually
throughout AAU like when I was in eighth
grade I was playing with like 10th
graders 11th graders so
um you know it kind of was an easy
transition for me in high school and
college because I've already played
against those girls that are quite a bit
older than me when did you first notice
the way Steph Curry played and what
impact has that had on you
I think I started really watching the
NBA probably like really closely
eighth or 8th grade or in high school
um you know and I I loved always having
it on
um and I think Steph Curry I mean he's
the most exciting player in all all of
basketball men's women's college Pros
whatever it is
um and I don't know I just think you
know what I love about it I think you
know it says how exciting women's
basketball can be you don't see Steph
Curry dunking the basketball every
single night it's the way he shoots the
basketball and women can do that too so
I think when people understand that they
can understand how good the women's game
is because the players in the women's
game are very very skilled uh just like
Steph is um but the way he shoots the
ball gets into it with the crowd
um you know those are a lot of the
things that I love to do too how would
you do shooting threes
oh I would lose for Steph come on but
you would love the challenge oh
absolutely I would totally sign up to
lose to him who wouldn't if he came to
Iowa like you know home court advantage
oh
I might make one or two on him but I
mean he's too no no no you guys are just
shooting the racks
oh
on my home court I'd be able to keep it
hopefully a little closer
um but I mean I think you're you're
being humble I think if he came to Iowa
and and you're there home court and the
fans are there you think I got a chance
uh you're the best shooter in college
basketball right now you know men or
women uh but I'm curious have you ever
been yelled at for shooting too far out
oh absolutely oh you have okay oh yeah I
think you know coach splitter's
obviously giving me a green light and
she knows those are shots I can make and
those are shots that I practice
um and I think you know when she
understands that you know that's why she
allows me to take them but I think you
know learning time and score when we
need them when we don't
um and you know just going back and
watching film those are you know I
usually go back and and watch it with
her and we talk about usually every shot
I take good or bad make or Miss so
um you know there are some that we could
probably get rid of at times but
um when you've made a couple you get a
couple heat checks and she definitely
allows that one which is pretty fun too
uh how important was the chief Super
Bowl victory oh that was awesome I'm a
huge Chiefs fan I actually went to the
game
um on Christmas Eve with my family
versus the Seahawks I'm at Arrowhead
which was pretty fun pretty fun
Christmas gift
um they got it done it was a freezing
one but it was super fun have You Met My
homes
I didn't meet Mahomes he ran like right
past me but I saw he tweeted about me
yesterday
um and he's reached out to me like and
dm'd me a couple times just saying how
fun I am to watch and
um but I mean come on he's like the most
exciting football player maybe ever
um so maybe there's a little comparison
between me and him and what we do a
little unorthodox yeah that you're
entertainers how's that that's fair
that's fair okay but do you hear like
LeBron or Kevin Durant did Kevin Durant
reach out to you yeah I think maybe my
freshman and my sophomore year I know
definitely last year uh yeah like you're
going wait who who's watching
I know it's pretty crazy uh because
those are the people like I idolized and
grew up watching
um and to see them comment about your
game or know that they were watching you
and your team it's it's pretty crazy it
makes you kind of kind of take a step
back and and love it for a second how
important is the WNBA to you
very important that's where I want to be
but you know I have another year here
and possibly one more after that just
because of covid so
um probably we'll have to make a
decision on that sometime next year I
really have no clue if what I'm going to
do is stay for an extra year or or leave
after next year but um you know I love
watching the WNBA I remember really
vividly my dad taking to me to my first
ever WNBA game Maya Moore was my
favorite player growing up she played
for the Minnesota Lynx so it was pretty
convenient that was only a four hour
trip from you know where I grew up and I
really remember you know getting to
watch her versus the Seattle Storm that
was like my first ever experience with
the WNBA when I was really young
would you take a pay cut though if you
go to the WNBA
necessarily I think that's what gets
lost sometimes I think people understand
you know nil like it's
you know Pro Sports too like you still
have all those endorsements you still
have you know the sponsorships and
whatnot so uh you're basically just a
professional athlete with that on top of
it too
um you know which was so it's not really
something that I would factor into my
decision of staying or going too much
when's the last time a professor asked
for an autograph
oh Professor I don't know about an
autograph but they definitely do love to
say say stuff to me in class which is
fine
um you know having professors that you
know watch you and understand the game
is always very nice well congratulations
so far what uh what classes uh do you
have today
oh actually Mondays are my day with no
class which is really nice but next but
tomorrow I got financial management and
marketing research so you know got it
loaded up on Tuesdays wait that is that
one class that you have on Tuesday oh
yeah I have two but I I take some online
too I take four classes oh come on hey
I'm getting close to getting my degree
so but you would you would seriously
consider staying two more years
yeah why
I don't know I think I just like love
this place I love getting to play in
front of a sold out crowd every single
night
um I don't know I love college
basketball
I don't know it would be hard to leave I
think what we've been what we've been
able to build has been super special too
um but more than anything you know I
love this program I love getting to play
for Coach blooter I love getting to play
with my best friends you know and
they're not only my teammates but I hang
out with them every second off the court
and you know it'll it'd be really hard
to leave that
um especially you know when you know you
can go to the WNBA even the year after
that
um but yeah I mean there's pros and cons
to both sides and I think you know it's
been hard for a lot of college athletes
to decide what to do uh just because you
know there are pros of staying in
college but also you know your dream of
reaching the next levels right there as
well yeah but you know there's got to be
a couple of players going gone I hope
that she doesn't stay an extra year so
we can get some shots here
uh yeah I think that's definitely a fair
assessment and
um you know like we've had a couple
players come back for like even their 60
or due to like injuries and things like
that so I think it's been a whole
different Dynamic that you know players
have had to go through but also coaches
like you the uncertainty of your roster
um and spots and who to recruit like
it's it's been challenging and difficult
and then the transfer portal is a whole
nother thing on top of that that you're
having to balance so
um it's really added a whole nother
element of you know college basketball
and you know what it already is
um so it's been kind of crazy to
navigate a lot of fun a lot of fun to
watch and uh continue to be unorthodox
continue to be Patrick Mahomes and uh
thank you good luck in the uh Big Ten
thank you so much thanks for having me
on good talking with you that's Caitlin
Clark best shooter in college basketball